[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
puzzles are plenty today both home and
abroad
winston church churchill once called
russia a riddle wrapped in a mystery
inside an enigma certainly as we speak
no one has much idea what vladimir putin
actually wants or what he will do with
the 130 000 troops poised on the border
with ukraine
for all we know by the time you watch
the repeat of this programme later today
there could be russian boots on
ukrainian soil
here at home political uncertainty
reigns on thursday morning the nation's
top cop cressida dick the commission of
the met declared that she planned to
stick around and see out her term of
office
by nightfall she'd resigned she said
because she had lost the confidence of
the mayor sadiq khan who only months
before had agreed to reappoint her to
the job
who's next your guess is as good as mine
and looming over all this the biggest
riddle of all can boris johnson survive
at number 10 and if he can for how long
a previous story leader ian duncan smith
this morning says that if the prime
minister's fine for lockdown breaches by
the police he's got to go
number 10 apparently says
not
necessarily
well let's see if our guests can help us
nail some of this jelly to the wall
northern ireland secretary brandon lewis
is here to discuss the pressing issues
focusing boris johnson's government at
the home as well as abroad this shadow
northern ireland secretary peter kyle
will also be joining me to get labour's
take
russia expert mark gagliotti will tell
us what he thinks vladimir putin's next
move over ukraine could be
it's also been a busy week for the
metropolitan police commissioner cresta
dick culminating in her resignation as i
said
former inspector of constabulary zoe
billingham will give us her view on the
future direction of the met
and the government has unveiled a new
plan to try to tackle growing nhs
waiting lists health service boss chris
hopson will tell us whether he thinks
it'll work
but first
i'm joined by the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis good morning
secretary of state good morning um i
know you can't share sensitive
intelligence with us but knowing what
you do know
how likely is a russian invasion of
ukraine
well i think as the defense secretary
has said over this weekend over the last
couple of days actually we have to be
realistic about uh with russia having a
hundred thousand troops now on the
roughly on the on the border there that
uh an imminent uh uh incursion by russia
is entirely possible and that's why
we've changed the travel advice and the
advice we've given to uk citizens who
are in ukraine do you think that the
reference to munich is that helpful in a
diplomatically sensitive moment well
actually i think what ben has outlined
there is given an explanation that
people understand particularly the
context of uh if people have seen the
the the new movie recently in the sense
of in the run-up to world war ii of
course there was lots of diplomatic work
people thought that was progressing but
of course it turned out not to and i
think what the defense secretary quite
rightly is doing he's drawing the
comparison and being clear that there's
a lot of diplomatic work going on
obviously both he and the foreign
secretary have been in russia themselves
this week
the russian state is saying that it is
not planning to invade but when you then
have a hundred thousand now a hundred
and thirty thousand we estimate troops
on the border that would indicate that
there is a possibility of an incursion
so it's that balance and that decision
and that um interpretation of the
difference between what we hope will be
a diplomatic outcome but the realistic
possibility that something
much more tragic could could occur but i
suppose one might say it's not that
technical to make the associations with
nazis well that that's not the point
actually the defence sector was making
it's very clear but what he was drawing
was the comparison between the
diplomatic uh attempts in the run-up to
world war ii and the diplomatic attempts
we're all putting in now we want to see
a diplomatic outcome we want to see a
peaceful outcome to this but we do have
to be cognizant of the fact as you said
quite rightly in the outcome the quote
by winston churchill is probably as true
today as it was back then in the context
of diplomatic talks with 130 000 troops
sitting right there on the board and
with that kind of accumulation there is
always the possibility and the the
ability for russia to move very very
swiftly and very quickly should it
decide to do so which obviously we hope
they won't well there is a school of
thought of course that says that
actually he's not really going to do
this but what he has done
bear in mind that russia is
at best a middle ranking economic power
it's got a lot of armed forces but not
as much as some
but he has achieved
a pretty spectacular strategic victory
already by exposing some deep fault
lines in the west and essentially having
everybody dancing to his tomb
actually i think what he has done is
bring the west nato and the european
alliance together to show that we're not
prepared and nobody should be prepared
to see a a country a democratic event
country have its borders threatened in
that way to be very clear that the world
is not going to put up with that we need
to see we want to see and we need to see
a diplomatic outcome to this and a
peaceful outcome but putting threats
like that on an independent country is
just inappropriate but he knows that in
truth
we've said that we would not put
soldiers into ukraine that we
would support them in whatever way we
can but essentially
this is
another
example of the west's failure to stand
up to russian aggression we can go back
as far as hungary in 1956 czechoslovakia
in 1968. or frankly don't go that back
that far crimea 2014 he's done it before
well it may well be that president putin
is testing the boundaries where he can
go and i think that's why it's been
important that the west and i have to
say the prime minister the foreign
secretary of defense secretary the uk as
a whole have been leading the way in
bringing that uh alliance together to be
very clear to russia that this is not
something we will tolerate we will we do
want to see a peaceful outcome to this
but nato is very very clear that it is
right that a democratic independent
country like the ukraine is allowed to
continue as an independent democratic
country without this kind of bullying or
threats
from a state like russia well it may be
a great alliance but some people will
say that's just an alliance of impotence
well actually no i think at the moment
what we've seen russia has been said
over the last few days with the meeting
they had with ben wallace that they are
not looking to invade if we can avoid
that and we have a diplomatic outcome
then it would have been successful but i
think it's also right that the west
working together is very clear that
should russia take a different course of
action that there will be repercussions
for that because it cannot be acceptable
that an independent state a democratic
state has that kind of threat put upon
it let alone that kind of incursion
should it happen well let's talk about
the um the the possibility of deterring
him if he's pausing um
you said that the west is united but
it's not entirely right is it for
example we know that the eu
bank eu's banks have an exposure to
russia of over 60 billion dollars that's
four times uh the exposure of american
banks so the americans can afford to
make threats but the eu may be more
cautious and surely that is actually
what mr wallace is talking about that
our eu partners may be a bit less
willing
than the united states
to take the tough uh deterrent steps uh
uh against mr putin and his allies by
cutting off their supplies to money and
so on well obviously we're not in that
position yet so we'll see what the the
outcome is well no i mean that's
interesting
already why aren't we taking steps
already to put to squeeze on him well no
trevor we've been very clear we will
bring in more sanctions that's one of
the repercussions there will be my first
question why are we waiting
we already have some sanctions against
russia already we've already taken the
power in the last week or so with the uh
statutory instrument in parliament to
allow the uk government to put more
sanctions in place but i spent uh
most of last week in the united states
predominantly on northern ireland
business for the uk government but what
is very clear the united states are
absolutely unified in this approach to
ensure that we do not see an incursion
and should russia take that kind of
activity that there will be
repercussions and that's one of the
things we've been very clear with russia
about and to be fair serve our partners
across europe as well well you know our
own parliament
hasn't been very um hasn't been very
convinced
of our uh fortitude in this um the
intelligence security committee
oh 18 months or more ago said
russian influence in the uk is the new
normal successive government have
welcomed the oligarchs and their money
with open arms providing them with a
means of recycling illicit finance
through the london laundromat and
connections at the highest levels with
access to uk companies and political
figures now look we've been saying for
years now we're going to clamp down
actually
russian billionaires are still whacking
their money through london's banks we
haven't actually done anything to hurt
putin
well i disagree with that i have to say
that before i was in this role i was the
security minister and one of these i
know without going into this kind of
areas that i can't really talk about in
terms of security intelligence we as a
country not only do we already have
sanctions against russia in place
actually is a country where i think we
are in a position where we've done
phenomenal work over the years so that
we're not that kind of venue we are an
attractive place for the world's money
and the world's businesses to invest and
to trade that's a good thing for the
city of london but we do have things in
place with this unexplained wealth
orders and a whole range of other
measures that mean that we are somewhere
that deters the kind of illegal activity
uh that you refer to and i have to say
if you look at some of the famous names
around the world that people talk about
in terms of that kind of russian
activity this is not a country that they
spend time in it's not a country they
come to and i do think we have those
nations in place to protect our
institutions well they don't have to
come here they can you know they can
stay in monaco whatever it is but their
money is here and i i'm sure i'm curious
about this because um
liz trust when she was sitting where you
are sitting a week or two ago said to me
that you're going to introduce new
legislation that will uh give you
greater powers to confiscate uh the
assets of these people and put pressure
on putin if actually we've been so
successful so far why do you need new
legislation well because look that's
actually quite simple so we yes we have
we have things like as i say unexplained
wealth orders is one of the tools in our
uh army that we can use and the and the
security services the police services do
use that it's been very successful um
it's actually one of the things that ben
wallace brought him and he was security
minister but we're always looking at how
we reassess as financial markets move as
technology moves you've always got to
keep these things under review to make
sure that you are able to have the tools
that you need to deal with what people
are trying to do it's the same with
fraud and internet activity more
generally these things are always moving
they're always developing and it's right
that our
teams keep that under review and that's
partly why even just last week we've
taken the power to bring in more
sanctions should we need to do so that's
something that the the teams are looking
at at the moment to make sure that if we
need to do that we have the ability to
do it and do it in a way that actually
has impact all right let's talk about
your own response with northern ireland
northern ireland is right now without
the first minister or a deputy first
minister
i understand you're just back from
washington where i gather you've been
talking about this to officials there
what were you hoping to achieve in your
trip to america well it was a long
planned trip actually it was around a
range of issues just generally about the
uh and i was in both washington and
boston about the investment that the us
has generally had in northern ireland
business investment which is hugely
important as part of delivering
prosperity and that's part of the priest
process you've seen jobs and
opportunities created and particularly
the burgeoning cyber and uh
technology sector in northern ireland
there's huge u.s interest in that so
looking at how we bolster that to how we
do more and how we develop that but also
talking to our friends and colleagues in
the united states to make sure that
they're aware of our position on the
northern ireland protocol the u.s have a
huge interest in what happens in
northern ireland their emotional
attachment their involvement in the good
friday agreement they've been a key
player in northern ireland over the
years and make sure that they understand
what are the problems with the north
island protocol and what is it we
envisage as a way through this well dude
you talked about the emotional
involvement
attachment of the americans and the
president biden himself of irish
heritage was clear in his election
campaign that um there would be no trade
deals until the protocol issue is sorted
out um
were you able to get them to budge on
that uh well actually the uh uh
secretary of state for international
trade and marie treville is going to the
us just in the next few weeks to how to
continue the discussions about traders
one of these i do find the u.s seas are
hugely important obviously one of their
strongest allies in the world they're
keen to trade with us to look at what
more we can do around global trade and
trade between the uk and the us that's
very positive but also making sure that
we're able to explain what are the
problems with the north liner protocol
what is it we want to see in terms of
finding a way through this we want to
get an agreement with the eu but that
does require the eu to show some
pragmatism and flexibility for the
benefit of the people of northern
ireland but biden he has more or less
said he would veto any deal until and
unless until there is agreement on the
protocol which presumably would involve
agreement uh by the nationalists as well
as the unionists well couple of these
are actual so first of all to be fair to
the president that's not exactly what he
has said what the us saying what well no
i'm not sure i'd entirely agree with
that what he has said and what the u.s
has consistently said is they want to
see an outcome agreed between the
parties and that respects the good
friday group that's exactly where the uk
government is you're quite right this is
an important factor this is something
that's got to work for the whole
community of northern ireland both the
national community and the unionist
community that's what we want to achieve
and let's also be very clear what often
gets missed in this discussion is the
problems with the protocol affect all of
the community in northern ireland
michelle o'neill the
who was deputy first minister the lead
sinn fein representative in northern
ireland herself has said there are
problems with the protocol we want to
get results so this is not just an issue
for unionism if you can't get access to
the products you need to get access to
as a consumer or as a business in
northern ireland which is currently the
case that affects everybody and that's
why we're seeing one of the examples of
this is the problems the jewish
community are having so this is not just
something about unionism this is
something we need to resolve for
everybody in northern ireland by the way
you've written an article on friday
which basically said uh us challenge the
unionists
to accept that if elections in may uh
result in a situation where the first
minister is from sinthane that they
would accept the post of
deputy first minister um
what are you going to do if they say no
because they haven't given you any
reassurances have they well they've none
of them are giving your assurances about
anything in the head of the election i
think the very quote that uh the
politicians all know given is they're
not commenting on what the outcome of
election may be before an election as a
politician i understand that but look
i'll be very clear about this as i was
last summer when she and fame were
trying to bring down the executive i
don't think the people in northern
ireland want to tolerate or are happy
with anybody threatening the
institutions of stormont that is part of
the group friday agreement it's how we
ensure we have good government in
northern ireland that devolved authority
to deliver on the issues like health and
education that need so much reform and
work in northern ireland we'll support
the executives to do that we want to see
a functioning executive all the parties
working together to do that all right
now on friday evening prime minister
received a questionnaire from
metropolitan police on his alleged
involvement in many parties that took
place in downing street um now you just
talked about the important issues that
face people in norman face people all
over
this country and most people would say
that every second of the prime
minister's attention should be on those
big issues
energy the ukraine uh ukraine the crisis
in the health service the economy but it
won't be
while he's answering questionnaires how
much longer are you going to let this go
on
well obviously the
investigation into this is a matter for
the police i'm not going to put time
frames on them they've got to be able to
do their job independently autonomously
and and see that through we've all been
very clear about that but i have to say
in the dealings i've had with the prime
minister he's absolutely focused on the
job in hand about what's what he's doing
for the british people whether it's on
the conversations i've had with him on
northern ireland be at the protocol or
the situation with the executive and i
know from cabinet meetings i was
attending most of the cabinet meeting
last week before i flew to the us his
work and his focus on our health service
and as you say on the issues with russia
and the ukraine yeah but as far as i
know prime minister is human and it
would be ridiculous to imagine that he's
not thinking about that uh as ian duncan
smith says in one papers this morning
i'm paraphrasing here that if he is
fined by the police he is toast and he
has to go well i haven't seen ian's
comments this morning but i have to say
what i have seen is a prime minister who
is absolutely focused and dedicated to
working on the issues that are affecting
people across the united kingdom whether
it's the cost of living whether it's the
issues as i say with russia and
obviously my uh portfolio of the issues
with north knight he is somebody who's
absolutely focused on that he works day
and night
to make sure we are delivering a country
that becomes even better for people so
he's paying no attention to the fact
that a former prime minister john major
says he had shredded the uk's reputation
another former prime minister teresa may
said public had a right to expect their
prime minister to have read the rules
understand the meaning of the rules and
set an example by following the rules
are all those people wrong and they see
not even bothered about that
no he's he will actually be very very
focused on the issues that matter to all
of us and look we are talking about
prime minister as foreign secretary
worked to bring the world together when
we had the uh strip-off situation when
we have the script situation sorry we've
got a prime minister who is now bringing
the world together in terms of how we do
with russian ukraine he's working within
this country about
dealing with this covered
after problem we've got the crisis we're
seeing in the health service dealing
with the backlog of that dealing with
the issues that people care about our
energy costs they're what he's focused
on and that's absolutely right where he
should be focused okay because that's
what makes our country better well let
me give one last go at this and this is
really a question to you and your
colleagues rather than the prime
minister um
you came into politics to support the
conservative cause national sovereignty
lower taxes
uh all freedom of the individual all of
that
every sunday you and your colleagues
have to come out and to try to explain
what the prime minister's socializing
means um is there any point
for you at which the great cause of the
israeli and churchill and thatcher
becomes more important than loyalty to
this prime minister
well i always enjoy coming to talk to
you on a sunday trevor and your
colleagues across the media so i i would
always be happy to come out yeah we're
fine do that so
we're
this is this is killing the cause i came
out
trevor as i said uh in a conversation
with somebody uh at the end of last week
i feel very very fortunate to be in the
to be honoured enough to be in a
position serving in the cabinet i've
served as a government minister under
three prime ministers when you ask by
prime ministers to serve your country i
think it's an honor to be able to do
that my focus is and always has been on
what we're doing for the people of our
country what i do for people in my
constituency and in this role obviously
the people of northern ireland i think
it's right that we're focused on that
and i have to say as i said to a few
moments ago my experiences that's what
the prime minister's focused on and
that's why he has my absolute 100 plus
loyalty look i think this is a prime
minister who's doing the right things
for our country he's got the big
decisions right i think he'll fight and
he will win as a result of that the next
general election all right well let's
deal with a couple of the real world
problems you're facing i mean this this
week um the resignation of crested dick
uh commission
of the met appears to take the
government by surprise and for you it
must be
somewhat alarming because she's one of
the key people in the fight against
terrorism which is a big priority for
you um
mi5 says that the national threat level
from terrorism is substantial and
northern ireland related threat level is
severe um for your point of view how
quickly
how quickly does a new commissioner have
to be in place well first just as a a
matter of fact i think it's important to
make the point obviously the policing of
terrorism in northern ireland is dealt
separately that's a matter for the ps
and i working with partners in northern
ireland rather than the metropolitan
police but all of the police forces work
together and obviously as the next
security minister the importance of the
mets role their national role in
counterterrorism is hugely important and
the teams who do that work that i've
always said i think are the best in the
world they're absolutely phenomenal it
is obviously important that we give them
the stability of having their leadership
dealt with as quickly as possible i know
that's something that the home sector
will be focused on doing but it's right
that we um give the space for the home
secretary and obviously consulting with
the mayor and others to make sure we get
the right person for that job but the
home sector will be dealing with that
very soon there are there's it's being
reported
by some newspapers that um the home
secretary would like to
uh essentially cut the mayor out of that
decision-making can you
uh confirm or tell us whether that is
true or not well as far as whether it's
just rumors i think it's always best to
avoid getting involved with rumors i
think the commissioner ultimately is
working with and for the mayor that's
obviously what's led to the decision the
rather odd decision in some ways because
as you rightly say the mayor just a few
months ago extended crested dick's
tenure as the uh as a commissioner for
london but look the focus will be on
getting the right person to succeed
crested a dick to take the metropolitan
police forward to put in the reforms
that we all need to see and uh deal with
some of the issues that the met has
faced recently and to continue ensuring
that the met can grow to be and and do
the work it does in particular in some
of those sensitive national areas is one
of the best if not arguably the best in
the world in the end does the government
think that uh the mayor's decision was
was a good one was it
was he right to withdraw his confidence
well i i say i don't know the details of
um of why sadiq khan having just very
recently um extended critics uh uh
tenure suddenly decided to uh withdraw
his comments and i absolutely respect
cressida's decision based on the
conversation we have with him that's
decision she's had to make i think the
focus has to now be on the fact that we
want to see the met moving forward there
are there is work to do it's a big
organization the largest police force in
the united kingdom and to get the
leadership in there that means it can go
forward and continue to develop and
change as it needs to to deal with the
issues he's had but also to deal with
the issues of uh policing on both the
national and the london scale that the
met has to deal with in the years ahead
mr lewis thank you so much for your time
right well let's get labour's take on
this with the shadow northern ireland
secretary peter kyle
good morning mr kyle um
the
northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis has just been giving me
his take on the political impasse in
northern are you satisfied with the what
he told me and the way he's handling it
well no there's been a really tough
lead-up to the challenges in northern
ireland there was two years ago there
was a deal that was negotiated by
brandon's predecessor which put forward
a raft of different measures which
needed legislation in westminster none
of it has been legislated for so some of
the key things are cultural packages
which would have introduced languages
things to do measures to deal with the
legacy issues of the violence in
northern ireland all of these have been
bungled and mismanaged uh in in the
years since that and none of it's been
introduced so that's destabilized the
system at the the politics of northern
ireland and then put into the middle of
that of course is a prime minister that
goes to northern ireland makes an
absolute solemn promise there'll be no
border down the irish sea and it has no
intention of honoring that promise and
in fact breaks it straight away and this
has put a division right down a you know
schism right down northern ireland at a
time when politics is already fragile so
the good friday agreement is under huge
pressure at the moment because we have a
a government that doesn't represent all
of northern ireland it only represents
part of the politics of northern ireland
we have a northern ireland secretary who
who doesn't really engage right across
all of the communities in northern
ireland and unfortunately when the
stormont collapsed brandon lewis gets on
a plane to washington he doesn't get on
a plane to belfast where he is needed to
bring people together and start to
hammer out a deal that will get storm on
up and running again so i am afraid that
this is a government who has played fast
and loose with the good friday agreement
and all of the measures which has
delivered police
peace stability and economic growth in
northern ireland and that's a real worry
so to be clear you are saying that the
uh decision by the unionists to
withdraw their leader uh from the first
minister's post um and the essential
paralysis of that government is really
boris johnson and brandon lewis's fault
it's not not really anything to do with
the north island parties
all political leaders all politicians
must take accept responsibility for
their own actions and
uh
i'm saying that the dup themselves have
been very explicit about that they're
not you know always blaming others but
there is a key thing here
if you look at the what the dup have
said and you look at the what the leader
jeffrey donaldson has said
it is very very clear when you look at
the world through their eyes they have
had a set of bargains with the tory
party and with boris johnson and every
one of the promises they've been made by
boris johnson has been broken to broken
they have been lied to repeatedly by
boris johnson and then we find out just
last week when jeffrey donaldson said
the prime minister has told him that the
protocol negotiations that are currently
underway only have a 30
uh possibility of success this is what
the prime minister is saying privately
there
this is the kind of thing that is going
on behind the scenes and it is no wonder
that is destabilizing northern ireland
okay i just want to get clear that
basically you're attributing really the
problems here to the government in uh
westminster and not really anything to
do with storm and if if labor
were in power what would you do to
resolve this let's not go back at what
you might not have done and all of that
but what would you be doing tomorrow to
resolve this
well not tomorrow i'd be there today i
wouldn't have gone to the whether i
would have cancelled that us trip and i
would have been there from the very
moment but yeah
back and telling me what you would not
have done just tell me what you would
have done
what would you do that's what i'm saying
i would be there and i wouldn't have
left if i was secretary of state i would
never let you do that get people around
the table figure out some of the
challenges and make things uh get things
onto the record there have been promises
made about the protocol for example
i think the government have played fast
and loose with its words about the
protocol it's clear they don't think the
negotiations are going to succeed they
have no plan b in place and if they do
trigger article 16 it will have impact
implications right the way across the
whole of the uk economy not just impact
in limited ways as it is currently the
northern ireland economy so all of these
things there's been there's been double
speak from the government there will be
no documents
the principle of the labour party being
the honest broker that northern ireland
needs
but mr carl so jeffrey johnson spoke to
us last week and the problem was that he
uh
he said some things about the government
he said the government could pay more
attention but essentially his objection
was to the way that the protocol
operates
what would you do differently about the
protocol than what the protocol would
have been very clear not how would you
get around the table but what would you
actually do what would you put to the eu
to solve the problem uh that of the
objection to the way it operates right
now
so the protocol has to evolve the labour
party has said that but the way to make
the protocol evolve is actually to have
functional relationships with the eu at
the moment they are dysfunctional liz
truss is still making the mistake that
david frost made by negotiating via
op-ed in the telegraph with the eu they
are not coming to any clear arrangements
we need a deal on veterinary services
that should be negotiable because
actually both sides have a very clear
landing zone for that and we need to
move on into the future to some more
consumer products i think we all know
where this is going the problem is that
it's not acceptable to a small faction
in the tory party that have the boris
johnson the prime minister to ransom
right now including this trust who's
playing to them because of our own
leadership ambitions the labour party
will incrementally and in a solid way
move forward adding on to the deal
improving the deal and showing that each
aspect of the new deal will work over
time to build the trust with the eu at
the moment the government is not acting
in good faith and it hasn't acted in
good faith it has delivered a deal that
it's trying to distance itself from this
is the deal boris johnson negotiated it
is his deal he didn't
okay could we move on to an area where
the government is not responsible where
we can talk about what
labour where labour is actually in
charge and talk about what labour does
and i want to talk about policing uh you
used to be shadow justice minister was
the mayor of london right to withdraw
his confidence from um the met police
commissioner
well there's a lot of discussion around
our country at the moment about people
at the top of organizations uh accepting
responsibility and what that actually
means so yes unfortunately it got to the
point where cressida dick had to accept
responsibility for all of the ongoing uh
revelations and inaction with reform in
the police and sadiq khan clearly got to
the point where he decided that she
needed to leave and actually that was
what accepting responsibility for the
person at the top meant i just wish that
boris johnson would do the same in the
way that he has mismanaged our country
and broken the rules
i'm not saying christopher chris who's
broken the rules but she has failed to
implement the changes that have been
needed over time
it would be great we do spend quite a
lot of time uh saying the words boris
johnson this program would be great if
we we talked about somebody else but
sticking with the issue of the met um
the mayor supported her reappointment
just a few months ago what what changed
well there's just more because most of
the events that
they quoted happened before now over
time so if you look at the revelations
that came out of the charing cross
police station the the independent
report revealed extreme misogyny and
other issues there not not just sexism
not the sort of thing that people could
put down to a way of interpreting the
behavior there there was extreme
misogyny now that's a new revelation on
top of all of the different revelations
which have come out from sarah everard
and beyond the public need change they
need they need to know that change
actually is taking place so i'm afraid
that this has been going ongoing this
has been ongoing for too long and the
public are just starting to wonder now
there was a a poll that's just come out
recently where now but only 43
of the public believe that the police
are able to tackle crime in the right
way this is the first time we've had
these kind of low figures before people
are losing confidence not just uh in the
police but the people who are managing
the police in the home office and the
home secretary herself
so something has to change and
unfortunately that has to start at the
top and we need a new approach it is
really sad because i know firsthand just
how dedicated the vast majority of
police are and the incredible job that
police do there are a lot of women
police officers who feel
very strongly about the issues that are
going on themselves this isn't just you
know people outside the police force
complaining about the people inside the
police force there are people inside the
police who are desperate for change in
reform that the public need and the
police need those people need to be
empowered uh yvette cooper today is
releasing a five-point plan to do so
which starts with putting women and
violence against women and girls uh as a
priority for the home office which needs
to be a priority for the police force in
terms of reform going forward but also
looking at all the other measures which
need to be proactively changed in the
police force including whistleblowing
including use of social media forgive me
can i interrupt you just first
sorry sorry to interrupt you but before
we have that much time left before we
uh move on i would like to um give you
the chance to say something about the
situation in ukraine
so kia
starman made a well-published sized
visit to nato
headquarters uh this week obviously i
think to reinforce the um
view that labour supports nato now
brandon lewis
has just been telling me that uh the
government will be introducing fresh
legislation that will allow the
government to confiscate the assets of
putin's friends but um as i said to him
the government's talked tough on this
before do you think this time that there
will be an effective regime put in place
and what would that look like for labor
i have absolutely no confidence that the
government are equipped to deal with
this simply because when you look at all
the taxation reforms that they they have
made to date they're doing so not in the
interests of the british economy they're
doing it in the interests of the people
who donate money to the tory party and
that includes a lot of russian people
we're not going to get the kind of
reforms that we need what we need to do
is have and they are not doing
transparency laws we need to know for
example
who is owning property particularly in
london and very expensive property
because at the moment there are all
sorts of very very easy ways that people
oligarchs and people with lots of
russian money who are laundering money
via the property market are doing so and
are able to hide it we need to reform
the law so that property is transparent
secondly companies house there are a lot
of people who are setting up very dodgy
companies in this country and is and
companies house enables uh russians to
hide who are the ultimate owners of
these companies who are investing money
in our country who are seeping money
into our our economy we need
transparency from that as well as that
needs reform
about transparency and got that point
but just
as a last question really
once you know and labor has already
named some of the people that you're
referring to what would you do about
them would you take confiscate their
properties would you freeze their bank
accounts what would you do
well we already have because labour
passed the uh
the unexplained wealth orders labor
party you know brought this this
legislation in but this government
doesn't use them so we do already have
the powers if people don't have it
explained wealth or we believe that the
origins of wealth are coming from uh you
know criminal activity or they shouldn't
they don't belong in our country the
powers are there they're just not used
so if the lord needs updating then of
course the labor party supports that
margaret hodges had a almost lifelong
career in politics trying to clear up
the dodgy money that's coming into our
economy the
magnining uh acts came from the
sanctions yeah
margaret hodge and labour party sort of
has implemented and support those
supported those acts we need to find the
source of these this money and then we
need to act upon it
thank you very much indeed mr kyle for
your time this morning
well let's get some more now on the
escalating crisis in ukraine
the defense secretary ben wallace says
the floundering diplomacy has a whiff of
munich about it so have efforts to
appease vladimir putin failed and is war
now inevitable
mark galliotti is a russian expert
russia expert and senior associate
fellow at the royal united services
institute and he joins me now uh good
morning mr galioti thank you so much for
joining joining
us what do you think
is going through
mr putin's mind this morning
well that's obviously the key question
that we're all trying to work out and i
think what we have to appreciate is the
extent to which putin is not the kind of
person who
fixes himself in a particular
track and timetable and rigorously
sticks to that he clearly believes in
creating options for himself and then
constantly reassessing them so i mean
what he will be doing today is we're
told that there is this war plan
that would actually be triggered on
wednesday
maybe maybe not but on the other hand
you know he'll be looking at well what
are the likely costs of actions what are
the likely benefits so this is i mean i
think he will constantly be reassessing
that and i think that is why it's so
important that we keep up both the the
pressure
but also make it clear that there are
off ramps because unfortunately if we
give him an option which is essentially
between escalation and capitulation then
he will probably escalate
what um what does an off-ramp look like
in this context that's a very
interesting concept
well what we have to realize is that
first of all russia believes that it has
some genuine security concerns now we
may disagree with a lot of the basic
precepts about whether nato is
aggressive and so forth but just simply
telling the russians that they're wrong
is not going to get them to say oh my
apologies we'll back away so they have
to have
an opportunity to basically talk through
their various issues
secondly there are a lot of specific
issues many of which frankly the
americans have already brought onto the
table that in some ways what we have to
do is talk them up as concessions to the
russians it may well and it does stick
in the craw to in effect act as
president putin's pr agents but in some
ways we we must get away from a
situation in which we're trying to push
him into a position where he will feel
that he's been defeated and instead we
want him to feel that what we're
offering which does not in any way
infringe on ukrainian sovereignty and
the wider european security architecture
but what is already there actually is a
genuine step forward for him so a lot of
this is frankly smoke and mirrors which
is after all what diplomacy is often all
about
well it's very interesting insight into
mr putin's psychology i talked to
mikhail kordekovsky the
russian billionaire and former friend i
suppose uh or associated of mr putin and
he
said that he was a little bit paranoid
and um
putin once said i haven't got quote in
front of me but i think putin once said
that the um the russian bear could be
quiet but on the other hand uh if it
uh stayed quiet then its enemies would
be uh tearing its claws and fangs out
and that therefore
i suppose in a way they had to be
aggressive
what do you think about that assessment
putin basically
is not just smart but also paranoid
i think there is a lot of paranoia in
not just putin but a lot of people
around him remember these people in
their late 60s and early 70s a lot of
them veterans of the kgb
all of them though products of the old
soviet system so they still have a lot
of the old attitudes and they're also
the ones who are probably most caught by
the traumatic end of empire which is
metastasized from uh what have we lost
to her and who took it from us so yes
there there is a very toxic
perspective on the west there but to go
back to the point about the
the russian bear
is look
unfortunately the russians have
internalized rightfully a sense that the
west only pays attention to russia when
russia causes problems for the west
and there's a certain amount of truth in
that and unfortunately that means
obviously without any way excusing what
putin is doing we shouldn't be surprised
that the russians continue to make
problems for us because that's how they
they get our attention but i think that
is the key thing if all he wanted to do
was crack the whip on ukraine he could
have done it by now he could have done
it much more quickly and with much less
of this kind of lengthy almost
theatrical build-up the fact that we
have this is a sign that at least putin
is hoping that he can get something
through negotiation rather than having
to unleash the troops with all the
massive political economic and social
costs that would involve
so that really leads us to the key
question
how likely do you think an invasion is
it sounds as though you think
not very likely
i mean that that is the question and
unfortunately then no doubt i will be
proven wrong whatever i i predict and i
think this is the thing at the moment
it's only putin who gets to decide and
we don't know what he's thinking for
certain my view is that invasion or some
substantial military escalation
is not his plan a
he's absolutely hoping to use all these
other methods intimidation diplomacy
covert attacks and so forth to get
enough of concessions that he feels he's
actually may manage to make his point
and put russia at the center of the
world again which is where he thinks it
should be
that doesn't mean though that military
escalation is not there as a plan b or a
plan c as an option if he really feels
that he's not going to get anything
anywhere then in a way he will probably
feel he has little option but to
escalate to a degree maybe not these
kind of apocalyptic scenarios we've been
hearing about rolling the tanks round
kiev and so forth but some kind of
military escalation just to make a point
but as i said i think that that's still
plan b
if i was going to guess do i think
there's going to be a war on wednesday
i will say not
sorry um
last question i guess um
in this rather delicate balance of
decision making
how
helpful is the
defense secretary's reference to munich
and essentially appeasement
i mean it's unfortunate not least
because it obviously cursed the russians
as nazi germany which you know for a
country which lost so much in the second
world war which still calls it the great
patriotic war that's a very neuralgic
point but i mean i think in in fairness
the russians are sophisticated enough to
realize that there is the the dialogue
that you have with your own domestic
audience and the dialogue you have with
other countries and in fact ben
wallace's visit to moscow seems to have
actually been pretty successful it was
very sober it wasn't a
highly publicized spat it was actually
two people trying to talk about
challenges and also the the parallel and
very important talks between chief of
the defence staff admiral radican and
his russian counterpart general
gerasimov so i mean actually in no sense
i think ben wallace has probably
accumulated enough credit that he can be
allowed a few rhetorical flourishes as
far as moscow is concerned
mark galioti thank you very much indeed
now on the great debates tomorrow night
we'll be asking do we have the leaders
we deserve has politics become a
spectator sport where personality is
valued over morals and character and our
celebrities and athletes now the role
models for the next generation
you can email the great debate at sky
dot uk if you want to get involved and
tune in anyway at 9 00 pm tomorrow
that'll be more of me i'm afraid but
there you go while many have criticized
christopher dick's record during five
years in charge of the metropolitan
police scandals surrounding the met are
nothing new to be honest i was reporting
on them as a young reporter in the 1980s
an independent review of the culture and
standards of behavior led by baroness
casey is about to get underway
the chances are that she'll give met
bosses some pretty grim reading
zoe billingham served as the inspector
of constabulary until last year and she
joins me now
good morning
morning
christopher dick most senior police
officer in the police service she
resigned on thursday
given her track record was that the
right thing for her to do
i was um really quite surprised by the
resignation trevor and my my view on
questa is she's led the
metropolitan police with care compassion
and candor she's uh she's really
generated great loyalty amongst
the frontline troops and
in effect she's been overtaken by a
series of what i can only describe as
catastrophic events she was walking
wasn't she an incredibly tough tight
rope so
post the uh appalling killing of sarah
everard and the erosion of public trust
she she really needed to focus on
rebuilding that trust while at the same
time kind of maintaining the confidence
of her own staff you know the vast
majority of the the men and women
working across the met are getting up
every day to do a great job for members
of the public but i think the kind of
the scale of the events so from sarah
everard through to the photographs of
nicole smallman and bieber henry which
was just a disgrace i think the the last
straw was really the charing cross
incident i can only describe it as an
abomination the comments that we heard
there i've never heard the likes in any
walk of life let alone policing
and although cressida had a plan and
i've looked at the plan and i think it
was a pretty good plan the trouble was
it wasn't moving at pace and that's what
led to the situation we found earlier on
in the week with her finding she had no
option but to resign
so do you think that the mayor in the
end was right to
say he
had no longer had confidence in her
that's got to be a decision for him and
i know i know that's a kind of a get out
of jail free kind of comment but the
issue
the issue that i think that he saw was
that the the reform wasn't happening at
pace the trouble i think that the mayor
and now the home secretary who leads on
the appointment of the met commissioner
the problem that they now have is
whoever the income the incoming
commissioner is they will have a very
very full inbox and they will have
precisely the same problems that crested
was contending with to deal with and the
problem here trevor is
at the root of this is there is a real
cultural issue in the met that needs to
be unpacked unpicked and dealt with and
we know that that's not going to happen
overnight but that needs to be at the
top of the new commissioner's inbox i
think cresta was a very talented leader
there are obviously many other talented
police officers up and down the country
will they do a better job than cresta
well that remains to be seen but she was
really at the forefront of police
leadership
um
one of the things that has been said
about this series of events is that um
the mayor
spoke in his statement this week about
the culture of misogyny racism and
homophobia
some reports say it reminded him of the
bad old days of police when he was
growing up
is that what a commissioner should
really mostly be judged on rather than
whether they are
catching bad people stopping burglaries
stopping night crime on the streets
it's you know it's a great question as
ever
the issue with public trust is is not
that it's a nice thing to have it's
essential because in this country we
police by consent
and when that
trust erodes the whole legitimacy of
policing erodes as well whether that's
in terms of people
reporting to the police whether that's
in terms of people from communities that
aren't properly represented within
policing coming forward and joining the
police it is so much at the heart of all
that the police do that it is right to
focus on trust but you know the other
part of your question is should the met
commissioner be focusing on the day job
too yeah absolutely i mean there's been
a series of reports over the last week
or so about the extent to which the
police are actually serving the public
well across the country
you know i find it pretty dismal that
only five percent of burglaries of
burglars are brought to justice one
percent of rapes end in conviction
i lead on violence against women and
girls or did in my former role and i was
astonished that three quarters of
domestic abuse-related crime reported to
the police was being closed down early
before
before the the offender is brought to
justice on the grounds of evidential
difficulties there's 1.6 million crimes
of domestic abuse
a year trevor you do do the math how how
many
how many of our victims are being uh
left in that position where they've
reported to the police but actually
they've not seen an outcome which they
think is just unfair so quite right in
terms of your question we've got to look
at both sides of this do the day job
well please use their powers well keep
keep keep the londoners safe but also
absolutely rebuilding trust is central
to all of this
well you've spoken um eloquently about
the day job and uh the
the data you've just given some of it uh
suggests that actually things are
getting
even worse and that
as you've quoted the figures on rape
which seem extraordinarily low on knife
crime um the number the proportion of
offenders uh given the immediate
custodial sentences decreased to 31
but from 2020 to 2021.
what is going wrong
i think there's a whole range of um
factors the police are really busy there
is no denying that and certainly when i
was her majesty's inspection of
constabulary we saw a massive increase
in crime going on to the books not
necessarily because there was crap more
crime but the police were getting a
whole lot better at reporting it
i think in some forces there's been a
tendency with all of this busyness
to look for easy routes to close crimes
down rather than to have to investigate
them rapidly and i'm always quite
depressed when i hear about crimes going
into what's called a crime resolution
desk which is where someone has a quick
look at the crime works out if there's
any leads to follow was there any cctv
was there any witnesses and makes a
really rapid decision
then not to investigate further the
police are there to do
very basic things in policing turn up
quick
listen to the victim and take what they
say at face value and and believe them
and do a proper investigation you know
do house to house inquiries look for
cctv not push it all back onto the
victim to do all that themselves and if
the police aren't turning up rapidly you
know that golden hour it's a bit of an
old cliche but that golden hour of
actually being able to gather that
evidence to build a case to bring the
offender to justice you know to some
extent again a cliche but back to some
of the basics in policing
across england wales i think
you um let's
find if i may just come back to this
point of trust that uh you spoke about
um
part of it is getting the day job done
but part of it presumably is also
behaving properly half of the police
employees who committed growth
misconduct in the last three years were
not dismissed of 118 cases where
standards breach was proven by
disciplinary panels
only 55 led to the sac according to an
analysis of figures by the uh
independent office for police conduct
and this is not just admit this is
across
the board
this is just not good enough is it
no it's not the public won't understand
it i don't understand it
it makes no sense you know i think the
whole
complexity of police regulations around
discipline and misconduct needs a
complete overhaul i hope the various
reviews that are ongoing
will completely look at this because if
people transgress in this position of
power and trust and this is what this is
in policing then they do need to be
brought to book and i don't think the
public i don't know the details behind
charing cross but i think it's hard for
the public to fathom
um that two of those officers who were
at the very least bystanders in that
abomination of that discussion on
whatsapp have now been have now been
promoted what sort of message is that
sending out across the organization so
yeah we definitely need to have a look
at misconduct we also trevor need to
look at the type of person that we want
to see within policing what are their
traits what's their ambitions why are
they joining policing in the first place
and when they have joined what what are
the police doing to make sure if there
are rotten apples that the counter
corruption measures in place are
sufficient to be able to root them out
zoe billingham thank you very much i
will speak again about this
thank you thank you
earlier this week the health secretary
sajid javid told mps that the nhs
waiting list in england will keep
growing for another two years
well it already stands at at least six
million
but the government says it's
long-awaited elective recovery plan
which aims to ensure no one has to wait
longer than two years for planned
hospital treatment by this summer will
help to reduce the backlog
but will an overstretched health service
be able to deliver chris hopson is chief
executive of nhs providers
morning chris um
the elective uh
recovery plan was presented to the
commons
uh peggy pardon
protected to the commons as a plan to
tackle this huge backlog um can it
reverse the fact that one in nine people
are actually on a waiting list for
hospital treatment in england
well trevor let's start with um the
impact on patients and i think it's
really important we talk a lot about the
statistics here but we just need to
remember that there are far too many
people who are waiting too long for
treatment as a result of the disruption
caused by covered and we just need to
remember that this means that there are
six million people who are in pain at
the worst end of things we know that
potentially these conditions can worsen
and potentially turn into um permanent
problems so every trust leader is
completely aware of the need to get
through these backlogs as quickly as
they possibly can we've worked very hard
on this plan it is stretching it is very
stretching i mean the um institute for
fiscal studies this week described the
headline ambition of getting to a around
130 percent of the levels of activity in
this area um by 2425 compared to what we
were doing pre covered so a 30 increase
in levels of activity they described
that as certainly ambitious so we've set
ourselves a very stretching target
and we know that we're going to need to
really do a number of different things
to ensure that target is delivered the
bit the bit that's the complexity here
trevor and i think a lot of the media
coverage this week i found slightly
frustrating is the problem the nhs has
got if you look at the core
waiting list issue about how big the
waiting list is we simply don't know how
many extra patients who didn't come
forward during covid are going to come
on to the waiting list so we could be
actually delivering that 130
uh headline target which would be
amazing fantastic and yet the waiting
list would still be going up so we just
need to be careful about saying we're
just going to judge nhs performance
solely by how big the waiting list is
because we know it is likely to grow
because all of those people who didn't
come forward during kobed are going to
come forward
well i want to come to that in a second
but if we may can we just deal with one
if you like public service point here
one of the um the flagship aspects of
this new plan is uh my planned care
which is described as an online service
uh informing patients about waiting
times and how to prepare for treatment
and the idea is that this will
reduce cancellations can you just
quickly explain how it actually is going
to work
yeah so what we're basically saying is
that in order for patients to and
there's a i think quite an interesting
concept here called weight well they
need to know two or three things the
first is they need to know when are they
likely to get treated uh and that will
prevent hopefully large numbers of
communications going backwards and
forwards about exactly when the
treatment will happen then the second
bit would be um just we know that about
a third of cancellations are due to
people who've got conditions such as
diabetes high blood pressure where those
conditions haven't perhaps been uh
managed as well as they might be in the
run-up to an operation so we get to the
operation day and then they effectively
find that we have to cancel so part of
this is about providing and supporting
appropriate information to enable people
with those conditions to be in in the
state of health that we need them to be
at the point when the operation happens
and i think all of us in the nhs know
trevor that we are behind not just the
private sector but other public services
in terms of our use of digital part of
that has been the lack of investment
that we've been able to make but this is
a very good example of where we do need
to ensure that we support our our our
patients to actually use our services in
a 21st century way so this is um you
know another way in which we can
increase and improve our use of digital
well okay thank you for that um look
there are a number of new targets and we
still have to see how they're going to
be operated
but
one of the questions that i think this
plan raises is that there are still
things that the health services have to
achieve before they get to these new
targets so for example
in august last year there was a record
high number of patients urgently
referred
by their gps waiting for over two months
for cancer treatment
we know that cancer patients often don't
have two months to spare and we're not
even meeting the diagnosis targets yet i
mean
shouldn't we be thinking about getting
that stuff done before we introduce some
of these new things
yes and that's absolutely what we're
going to be doing we've made a very
clear commitment that we will prioritize
the most urgent cases of which as you
quite correctly identify and the most
urgent cancer cases are key and that's
why we've set ourselves a target that
seventy-five percent of g regife
referrals gp referrals for cancer
diagnosis uh will actually be seen
within um 28 days because we know that's
a really really important task one of
the issues we've got here trevor is that
if you're a trust leader and you've got
a very large number of people who are
waiting there is quite a sophisticated
but incredibly important operation to do
in terms of clinical prioritization and
when you talk to trust leaders what
they'll tell you is that they spend a
huge amount of time working with
frontline clinicians working with
computer computer systems patient
records to really identify uh in what
order we should be bringing patients in
and of course we will focus on those who
are um you know have the greatest
clinical priority those who are most in
urgent need but but this is in the
context of and now let's be really clear
about this nobody in the nhs would want
to see a waiting list of this size and
what's happened is we've had two
problems the first is we've had
insufficient capacity in the nhs after a
decade of the longest and deepest
financial squeeze in nhs history so that
so the waiting list were already growing
before we went into covid and then what
we've had is this huge disruption over
the covert period so these waiting lists
are are you know they're by far the
biggest we've seen for a very very long
time
we've spoken about this issue of
capacity before
and to the lay person that is a problem
about numbers of staff you're i think 93
000 people showed overall nearly 40 000
nurses short what can possibly be done
about that
other than perhaps
some really determined and intentional
recruitment uh from
other countries
well trevor you put your finger on it
really really well and we're just
literally in the process of finalizing
the health and care bill where there was
a whole bunch of us who were saying to
the government you have to have a proper
long-term workforce plan and if it takes
three years years to train a nurse and
13 years to train a consultant you have
a very significant lead time here so how
can you expect the nhs to have the right
level of workforce that it needs if it's
not got a proper workforce plan in place
and there's been an amendment that was
debated in the lords that was originally
proposed by jeremy hunt in the commons
which it's incredibly important that we
um that we pass so the answer trevor is
that there is good news down the track
in that we are now seeing very high
higher levels of people entering
training but if i'm really honest we've
got this very difficult period over the
next two or three years where we know we
won't have enough staff and you're
absolutely right there will be a
significant premium on recruiting people
um from overseas but that's not a
comfortable place to be it also isn't
particularly helpful for the nations uh
from which we're taking those staff so
we've got to have a proper workforce
plan and if i'm honest i'm incredibly
frustrated about the fact that the
government will not sign up to the idea
of a proper long-term workforce plan
which is what we have in every other
sector of our economy and what we have
in every other national health system i
can't understand why the government
won't sign up to what seems to me to be
blindingly
chris hopson thank you very much indeed
thank you trevor
well that is all we have time for from
the main show today uh one thing we have
we can be certain about there will be at
some point sometime soon a new top cop
in britain what we don't know is uh
whether mr putin and his people will
find themselves in ukraine by this time
next week
though from what we've heard today it
feels like he may already have won the
game that he's playing
and of course the biggest question we
still don't know who will be prime
minister next sunday i'll be here to
tell you then